welcome to this first Easter service in
Christ Chapel it'll still colleges
brand-spanking-new chapel
I'm gonna speak especially to the
Diaspora the students who are not here
and I want you to remember your college
it remembers you and yet it's a
commentary on human things that I am
almost alone in this Chapel today you're
not here a plague has come upon us we
don't know when it's going to end but we
do know that it's going to end and we
know because of Lent and Easter we know
that soon will be the celebration of the
greatest exhibition of the eternal in
history the resurrection of Jesus and we
know that we will get back together
because we can't really be a part and
the reason we can't be a part is because
of the subject we study and the
friendship we form around that subject
our subject is the good and the good
points up to the perfect and the eternal
that would be God and so of course the
human dwelling in the soul upon those
eternal things is the nearest thing to
heaven on this earth and it's the
highest kind of friendship it produces a
love among all those who do it and
toward the things they study so I can
say truly that we miss you but also that
we will be back as surely as it's true
that Easter will come soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Alleluia Christ our Passover husband
sacrificed for us therefore let us keep
the feast not with the old leaven the
leaven of malice and evil but with the
unleavened bread of sincerity and truth
Alleluia Christ being raised from the
dead will never die again death
no longer has dominion over him the
death that he died he died to sin once
for all but the life he lives he lives
to God
so also consider yourselves dead to sin
and alive to God in Jesus Christ our
Lord hallelujah
Christ has been raised from the dead the
firstfruits of those who have fallen
asleep for since by a man came death by
a man has come also the resurrection of
the Dead for as an Adam all die so also
in Christ shall all be made alive
alleluia alleluia
Christ is risen the Lord is risen indeed
Alleluia
you have just heard read a very ancient
hem called
the pass can Ostrom and like all good
hymns it's words are grounded in the
sure soil of God's most holy word in
this case it consists of nothing but
biblical words and it has been used by
Christians on Easter day for centuries
the choice says I hope you will see is a
just and a right one this hymn collects
for us three of the most significant
passages in the New Testament letters
concerning our Lord's resurrection which
we celebrate today from first
Corinthians chapter 5 Romans chapter 6
and first Corinthians chapter 15 we see
in rapid-fire summary fashion the
Apostolic testimony concerning that very
first Easter day
it speaks of Christ our Passover lamb
who's a blood sprinkle upon us the curse
and scourge of death passes by us
without harm
it speaks of cry
our life breaking down the Dominion of
sin and death and ushering in a kingdom
of righteousness and life for all
believers it speaks of Christ our
firstfruits who has ushered in a great
harvest of immortality for all who stand
in the lineage of Adam bringing the
Exile back into the garden of sweet
intimate embrace with God from which he
once led our race in bitter banishment
now this is certainly the good
theological truth of our festival today
that the devil's greatest enemy against
us the Swift sword of death has been
beaten into a plowshare turning the
rocky soil of cursed earth into a
fertile field which springs forth
holiness and righteousness Christ our
Lord is risen today trampling down death
by death and to those in the grave
restoring life he who knew no sin became
sin for us that we might become the
righteousness of God though he was rich
yet for our sake he became poor so that
we by his poverty might become rich but
these sacred texts tell us far more than
merely what Christ has accomplished for
us they speak also of why Christ has
accomplished it they call us to a right
response look more closely with me this
hymn speaks of our leaving behind the
old leaven of malice and evil and taking
up in its place the fresh victuals of
sincerity and truth it speaks of a great
Hope which is now ours that this mortal
life is not the measure of our existence
but that we enjoy a hidden citizenship
in the Kingdom of Heaven to which these
feeble bodies of ours will be one day
raised up in the glorious immortality it
speaks of a new mind that we have
received by his most gracious hand by
which we consider ourselves dead to
which is to say that our old lives have
been crucified with Jesus by the
mysterious workings of His Holy Spirit
now poured out upon us and we now know
ourselves to be alive in God in the
sight of him whose opinion alone it
really matters the resurrection of
Christ's human body now gives life to
our mortal bodies before his great
victory one for us we did not have the
strength in these frail limbs to honor
him as we should we did not have life in
these stony hearts of ours to pay the
homage to him that he deserves but by
his victory for us fought for and won in
a mortal nature just like ours we now
have the power the potential in him to
live a life of righteousness it's
important to stress here what might be
easily missed the contribution of the
Christian religion on the world stage is
not that of a lofty moral ethic as lofty
as our ethic is other world religions
offer us stringent moral codes and
sacred duties only Christianity calls us
to virtue by first telling us that we do
not have the power within ourselves to
do it but that God has become like one
of us and has done it on our behalf and
only now does he call us
does he empower us to follow his example
other world religions offer us great
heights to which the people are summoned
to ascend only Christianity speaks of
our God coming down to earth to reach us
and to carry us back to the top again
aloft on his shoulders like a child
Christ has been raised from the dead
therefore live a life of truth therefore
rid your life of sin therefore consider
yourself alive to God Christians never
speak of their sacred duties before they
first proclaim the good news of what God
has accomplished for us in Jesus Christ
and only then do we call for a right
response to believe to repent to live a
new life now which becomes it not to
earn our Heavenly Father's embrace which
is now freely given to us in Jesus but
to enjoy it
do you believe this Easter day I
conclude by addressing the elephant in
the room our current global pandemic I
have not mentioned it until now quite
intentionally I have not mentioned it
because it does not change a lick what
Easter means for us what we celebrate
today what God has accomplished for us
in Jesus Christ's Kovan changes not an
iota out the victory of our God from the
perspective of his heavenly throne the
earth is now as it always has been
indeed if the Apostle Paul is to be
believed in the eighth chapter of his
letter to the Romans this present trial
cannot even begin to compare with the
glory that awaits us in Jesus it is a
tiny speck against the backdrop of his
ineffable majesty
but that also means that this current
crisis changes not a lick our Lord
summons to us to live a life as becomes
this good news he has secured in human
flesh a heavenly power which no evil in
this world can stop and that power he
still has he still wields in his body
and he shines at forth now into ours by
the power of His Holy Spirit he is
poured out upon us and so the life of
faith the habits of prayer study
disciplined service worship and thanks
the life of love for God and for our
neighbor it does not stop as the world
around us stops it does not bend the
knee as the world around us has been
brought to its it does not hide itself
under a bushel as the world around us
hides away in homes now is the time even
now no aspect
surely now to offer our lives our souls
and bodies as a fragrant sacrifice to
God now granted the current disruption
of our lives may make this work a bit
harder for us harder to enter into
harder to push through but how much more
so then is this time a fertile soil for
growth let us not miss the opportunity
afforded us by this adversity
let us continue to strive to finish the
race that is set before us behind our
champion who is Jesus Christ at
Hillsdale College we seek the highest
things the noblest truths the most
sublime beauties and nothing can be
higher than this to look into the face a
world now reeling in its own mortality
and nevertheless to sing with boldness
our Easter hymn alleluia alleluia
alleluia for Christ our Lord is risen
this day so let us keep the feast and
live our new lives for God O God who for
our redemption gave your only begotten
Son to die upon the cross and by his
glorious resurrection delivered us from
the devil and the power of death grant
ask us to die daily to sin that we may
live with him in the joy of his
resurrection who lives and reigns with
you and the Holy Spirit now in forever
amen and now may the God of peace who
brought again from the dead our Lord
Jesus Christ that great Shepherd of the
Sheep by the blood of the everlasting
covenant make you perfect in every good
work to do his will working in you that
which is well pleasing in his sight and
the blessing of God Almighty the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit be among you
and remain with you always
amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]